(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- [Leslie] Oh my God!
- You look amazing! The boots!
How are you?
- How you doing? Oh my God you look so-
- [Kelly] Thank you, did you hear her?
- Oh my God, (clapping) first
of all I want to say, girl!
(audience laughing)
- She's up here now and she-
- You need to get a band!
- Yeah, yeah!
- You need a band!
- I love you!
- [Kelly] She's incredible.
- [Leslie] Get a band!
(audience cheering)
- [Leslie] You're good!
- [Kelly] Well, you're back,
you're in this building again.
- Yes.
- You were here for a while.
- Yeah, you're used to "30 Rock."
- I didn't even realize
that the last time I was
on here, we was in L.A.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I didn't even realize that.
- [Kelly] I know, I did.
- You look so dang good.
- That's why I'm happier here.
- You do!
(audience cheering)
- I love it here.
- You look so good, Kelly.
- Thank you.
Um, but anyways, so do you remember
like your first audition for SNL?
- You can't forget stuff like that.
- [Kelly] I do.
- Yeah, I mean, it was just intense.
(audience laughing)
- It was intense.
Yeah, right there on 8H.
- Do people laugh at those?
- [Leslie] Well-
- Do they help you?
- [Leslie] You know, usually
they don't laugh, but...
- [Kelly] You're like,
but I'm funny! (laughing)
(audience laughing)
- I mean, I did a whole cartwheel.
I did a cartwheel-
- A whole cartwheel?
- I did a cartwheel in my audition.
Of course they laughed.
- [Kelly] Oh my gosh.
You're so funny.
- They was like, she's insane!
- I know, but it must be
such a wonderful gift.
You walk in a room and you
leave it better than it was.
You're like, you have that kind of-
- Oh, that is the nicest thing!
(audience cheering)
- You have that personal,
like that personality.
- I don't know if
everybody would say that!
- They would, you make us laugh.
- That's the nicest thing ever, hmm...
- [Kelly] I know, you do!
- You ask some of my
relatives, they was like,
she leaves the room better?
(audience laughing)
- That's because they're used to you.
Wait, so it was a big thing for you too,
because I didn't realize that
you were a writer on SNL too.
That was actually the first thing-
- That's, well actually,
I didn't get hired as a cast member.
You know, they hired Sasheer.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Leslie] And then I
got hired as a writer.
Well, which I told him,
I was like, you know, I'm not a writer.
You know, I was like, I like
to be in front of the camera.
- You're probably both.
- But he was like,
and he probably was saying that
too, like, you are a writer,
you just ain't giving it, you know, love.
But he was like, I
don't know what you are.
Just come.
He was like, I didn't know I needed you
until I saw you, so come.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- So I was like, good, okay.
- Don't you want someone
to say that to you?
Yeah, that's nice.
- I mean, I want a man to say that.
- [Kelly] Yeah, me too.
(audience laughing)
♪ Hey ♪
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
Amen.
So wait.
(audience cheering)
Do you feel like there's been a change
for Black female comics on SNL?
- Yes, I do.
I think that was the main reason too
I also went to audition
'cause I was like, you know,
just like Chris said, you know,
they don't get the opportunity
to really find a lot
of Black females because we
don't get to be in the places
that they go to look for.
- Ah.
- [Leslie] And I'm not trying to-
- Opportunity, yeah-
- Use race anything,
I'm just telling you what it is, like.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I don't know where The
Groundlings is, I mean-
(Kelly laughing)
- 'Cause that's the place-
- I don't. I don't know
where U.C.B. all that,
I don't know where that is.
- [Kelly] No, everybody does say that.
- [Leslie] But I do know
where the comedy clubs is,
so even when Chris told me I
was going for the audition,
I was like, yo, dude, what am I gonna do?
I don't have characters.
He was like, you're the
character, just do comedy.
And I was like, okay.
- You are the character.
- Whatever, you know, so.
I feel like my whole thing was like,
if y'all don't know about Black females,
I'm gonna go and let you know
and let you see one of the good ones
so then you can go start looking for more.
(everybody clapping and cheering)
- I love it.
No, the domino effect of
that, that's incredible.
You're hosting "The
Daily Show" again, right?
- Yes, yes, yes.
(audience cheering and clapping)
- Do you love doing it?
- I'm not gonna lie to you, I love it.
- It's so fun! I love hosting.
- I love it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause I love to talk.
- Yeah.
- I love the fuss,
and I love to be funny.
I love to bring joy, I
love when people laugh.
It's not just about me making you laugh,
it is a function.
I am a doctor and I am
prescribing you medicine.
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, I actually agree with that.
- And that's so real.
Whenever you can laugh,
like you can laugh through something.
No, hey, listen,
everybody need to cry too.
That's a function also.
- We do that a lot here.
- But laughter.
Laughter, you gotta keep a balance.
That's what's wrong with us right now.
We don't have a balance.
(audience applauding)
- So, you're such a great
motivational person as well.
Is there a reason why you
felt like the memoir is
important now to, I don't
know if I'd ever do it.
- Okay well first, everybody always like,
want me to say something really, you know,
wonderful about why I wrote this book.
But it was like, book agent called me
and was like, you wanna write a book?
(audience laughing)
Yeah (laughs), let's go!
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
I advise you to do it
because you can do it your own way.
Trust me, that first version?
Thank God that one didn't get out.
- Ah.
- 'Cause it had so much stuff in there
because it's a lot of pain.
It's a lot of pain, it's a
lot of you remembering stuff,
and stuffing it in.
But then when I read
it, I was like, oh girl,
you do not feel like that now.
These are things that happened to you,
now explain them so people can understand
that you can still go through stuff
and end up on the good side of it.
You still can go through
bad and treat people well.
You don't have to be a (beep).
Now I had-
- Now I had to go, I say it all the time.
- Yeah, yeah.
(audience applauding)
- Did you, I heard you started at,
was it a college comedy competition?
- [Leslie] Yes, yes, yes.
- That's kind of a hard, like, your peers.
That's hard. Were you nervous?
- No, I was already funny.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- And just working on that humble.
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
That's me too look, you
feel good you gotta say it-
- Because it's not even
about being conceited,
it's about being convinced.
- No, yeah!
- You know, it's like if your
doctor walked into an office,
you want him to be like,
yeah, I'm your doctor
and I know how to do this
and this is the treatment
and boom, boom, boom.
You don't want your
doctor to walk in and go,
I'm kind of a good doctor.
- [Kelly] I kind of feel like...
- They said I'm okay.
No, you want somebody that's
confident and I'm confident.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm confident because I've worked
and I've done the work
and I'm good at what I do.
- Yeah.
- So if that's what shows,
then take that note.
Because if you're good at what you do,
you're good at what you do.
And this is, I really wanna say this.
I am Leslie Jones, but there's gonna be
a billion Leslie Jones after me
and I want to make it okay for them.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That's what I want.
(audience cheering)
Now I'm starting to sweat.
- [Kelly] Look, we got,
no, we have tissue.
We get tissue. We have tissue.
- Because you know,
when I preach, I sweat.
- No, that's so true.
Like, I literally, thank you Brendan.
You can come on.
This is Brendan, give it up.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
- No, I agree with that.
It was my therapist,
I had to go to therapy to find that out.
But it was like-
- [Leslie] No, real talk.
- Hey, why don't you
start treating yourself
how you treat others.
And it's like, wait, what?
And that was hard to hear.
- No, but we lie to
ourselves all the time.
For some reason, we like
to have ourself in misery.
We live with it.
We lie and we retell a
story and it be lying.
You be lying!
(audience laughing)
You be lying to hurt yourself
and that does not make sense.
- Maybe, let's just switch places here.
I'm gonna need like the, I'm gonna just-
- Lie down.
(audience cheering)
- Here's what happened.
I'm just kidding.
(Leslie and Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God. Wait, we
found an image though of,
it's of the school newspaper
that interviewed you
and I love it.
"I think a good comedian",
that's what you said,
"should be able to relate to the audience
and talk about things in a
natural way" like you just did.
So you still believe this.
You're still rolling with,
you're rocking with this.
- Where did you find that?
(audience laughing)
- Last night I snuck into to your house.
- (gasps) No!
- I'm just kidding.
- No, wait. Yo, I don't even have this.
That's crazy. I said that?
- [Kelly] Yeah. (laughing)
And it, but you know what
I think is beautiful?
Somebody in this audience,
including myself,
needed to hear exactly what you just said.
But I think what's incredible
is you said this a long time ago,
but you're still living
that same like truth.
You're still living those same words,
which is kind of incredible.
So we are gonna best friends.
- Because that's what, that's...
Man.
- Be my best friend, okay. (laughing)
- That it's just a mix, ooh!
(audience aws)
- [Kelly] Do you remember
that moment though?
Like being a part?
It couldn't have been easy the whole time.
You had to bomb once, right?
(audience laughing)
- You're wrong.
- [Kelly] Take a minute.
(everybody laughing)
- Did I just Oprah you?
Did I just Oprah you?
- [Leslie] Yes, you just Oprah'd me.
- I was like, I didn't
even mean to. Oh my God.
No, I just think it's a
beautiful thing how...
(audience laughing)
It's a beautiful thing,
like how, you know,
you find these things from
like when you were younger
and that dreamer and then
you didn't lose that.
That essence is still in you.
That's awesome.
We're going to get you a
photocopy of this, okay?
(audience laughing and clapping)
I'm gonna have it like-
Aww!
Why are you so moved right now?
I need to know exactly why.
- 'Cause I didn't think I was that smart.
(audience laughing and cheering)
- [Kelly] You are-
- Not then, not then.
I was a wreck, I was a mess!
- [Kelly] Maybe you
thought you were a mess.
Maybe you were living in that-
- I was a 19-year-old mess.
- We all were.
What 19-year-old has
their (beep) together?
(audience laughing)
Like, nobody knows (beep) at 19.
- [Leslie] I done messed up my makeup-
- You can't air any of that, sorry.
- Lord have mercy! I came
out here to be beautiful!
- Okay (laughs and claps) okay wait.
- Kelly!
- We're gonna get touched
up in a commercial break.
Leslie's book-
- You gotta get my makeup girl out here!
- Leslie, Lo-Lo!
- Lo-Lo!
- Mine's Glow-Glow, that's so funny.
(audience cheering)
Leslie's book is called
"Leslie bleeping Jones."
It's out now.
You gotta go get it.
It's gonna change your life!
- [Leslie] Oh my God!
- And everyone in our
audience is getting a copy!
(audience cheering)